it's official war zone is a free-to-play
upgraded version of blackout with new
modes and features here's everything you
need to know about the standalone Call
of Duty game first of all war zone has
two game modes battle royale and plunder
battle royale is mostly the blackout you
remember but it now supports a hundred
and fifty players you can drop onto the
map and solos duo's and trios scavenge
for weapons and other gear and fight to
be the last soldier standing but let's
say you get downed the first time you
get eliminated you'll be sent to a new
location called the Gulag if you manage
to beat another eliminated player in a
1v1 shootout you'll be able to redeploy
you'll find cash across the battle
royale map - this can be spent at buy
stations which are marked on the map
with a shopping cart
Activision says you'll be able to
purchase things like kill streaks
redeploy tokens to revive your teammates
and kits for reviving yourself - then
there's plunder where your goal is to
actually make the most money you'll get
cash from looting stealing from other
players and completing objectives called
contracts there are several kinds of
contracts to fulfill recon contracts for
example tasks you withholding a control
point on the map similar to domination
mode both of these modes take place on
the same map a big city called for dansk
according to Activision it has 300
different points of interest and they
range from dense city blocks to more
open rural areas you can get around the
map on several vehicles - players can
ride on an ATV offering little
protection but high speed the tactical
Rover is also fast and mostly
unprotected but four players can ride
together
the SUV can also seat four players but
it does trade some speed for more
protection the slowest of these grounded
vehicles is the cargo truck which holds
your full squad and equipment and offers
high defense
lastly you can take to the skies in a
four seater helicopter Activision hasn't
announced for persons squads to
accompany some of these vehicles but
it's possible we'll see them added in
the future so when can you play warzone
the game launches for ps4 Xbox one and
PC on March 10th and to reiterate it is
free to play activision expects it to go
live around noon Pacific time
standalone game weighs in between 83 and
110 gigabytes if you don't own modern
warfare already if you do own it you'll
be able to jump in a little earlier you
can download the warzone update around a
much smaller 20 gigs and jump in at 8:00
a.m. Pacific it's also worth noting that
your battle pass items operators weapons
and customization items will all carry
over for modern warfare into warzone
progress owned in warzone also counts
toward your overall multiplayer rankings
and there's no level cap in warzone
what's more if you download it by itself
and pick up modern warfare down the road
your progress and rewards will also
transfer backwards so that's everything
you need to know about Call of Duty war
zone expect to see more coverage and
gameplay on GameSpot and we'll see you
in the city or at least in the gulag